- [Voiceover] So here I want to talk about
the gradient and the
context of a contour map.
So let's say we have a
multivariable function.
A two-variable function f of x,y.
And this one is just
gonna equal x times y.
So we can visualize
this with a contour map
just on the xy plane.
So what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna go over here.
I'm gonna draw a y axis
and my x axis.
All right, so
this right here represents x values.
And this represents y values.
And this is entirely the input space.
And I have a video on contour maps
if you are unfamiliar with them
or are feeling uncomfortable.
And the contour map for x times y
looks something like this.
And each one of these lines
represents a constant value.
So you might be thinking that you have,
you know, let's say you want a
the constant value for f of
x times y is equal to two.
Would be one of these lines.
That would be what one of
these lines represents.
And a way you could think about that
for this specific function
is you saying hey, when
is x times y equal to two?
And that's kind of like the graph
y equals two over x.
And that's where you would
see something like this.
So all of these lines,
they're representing constant
values for the function.
And now I want to take a
look at the gradient field.
And the gradient, if you'll remember,
is just a vector full of the
partial derivatives of f.
And let's just actually write it out.
The gradient of f, with
our little del symbol,
is a function of x and y.
And it's a vector-valued function
whose first coordinate is
the partial derivative
of f with respect to x.
And the second component
is the partial derivative
with respect to y.
So when we actually do
this for our function,
we take the partial
derivative with respect to x.
It takes a look.
X looks like a variable.
Y looks like a constant.
The derivative of this whole thing
is just equal to that constant, y.
And then kind of the reverse for when you
take the partial derivative
with respect to y.
Y looks like a variable.
X looks like a constant.
And the derivative is
just that constant, x.
And this can be visualized
as a vector field
in the xy plane as well.
You know, at every given point, xy,
so you kind of go like
x equals two, y equals one, let's say.
So that would be x
equals two, y equals one.
You would plug in the vector
and see what should be output.
And at this point, the point is two, one.
The desired output kind of swaps those.
So we're looking somehow to
draw the vector one, two.
So you would expect to
see the vector that has
an x component of one
and a y component of two.
Something like that.
But it's probably gonna be scaled down
because of the way we
usually draw vector fields.
And the entire field looks like this.
So I'll go ahead and
erase what I had going on.
Since this is a little bit clearer.
And remember, we scaled
down all the vectors.
The color represents length.
So red here is super-long.
Blue is gonna be kind of short.
And one thing worth noticing.
If you take a look at all
of the given points around,
if the vector is crossing a contour line,
it's perpendicular to that contour line.
Wherever you go.
You know, you go down here,
this vector's perpendicular
to the contour line.
Over here, perpendicular
And this happens everywhere.
And it's for a very good reason.
And it's also super-useful.
So let's just think about
what that reason should be.
Let's zoom in on a point.
So I'm gonna clear up our function here.
Clear up all of the information about it.
And just zoom in on one of those points.
So let's say like right here.
We'll take that guy
and kind of imagine
zooming in and saying what's
going on in that region?
So you've got some kind of contour line.
And it's swooping down like this.
And that represents some kind of value.
Let's say that represents
the value f equals two.
And, you know, it might not
be a perfect straight line.
But the more you zoom in,
the more it looks like a straight line.
And when you want to
interpret the gradient vector.
If you remember, in the
video about how to interpret
the gradient in the context of a graph,
I said it points in the
direction of steepest descent.
So if you imagine all the possible vectors
kind of pointing away from this point,
the question is, which
direction should you move
to increase the value of f the fastest?
And there's two ways
of thinking about that.
One is to look at all of
these different directions
and say which one increases x the most?
But another way of doing it
would be to get rid of them all
and just take a look
at another contour line
that represents a slight increase.
All right, so let's say
you're taking a look at a contour line,
another contour line.
Something like this.
And maybe that represents
something that's right next to it.
Like 2.1.
That represents, you know,
another value that's very close.
And if I were a better artist,
and this was more representative,
it would look like a line
that's parallel to the original one.
Because if you change the output
by just a little bit,
the set of in points that look like it
is pretty much the same but
just shifted over a bit.
So another way we can think
about the gradient here
is to say of all of the vectors that move
from this output of two
up to the value of 2.1.
You know, you're looking at
all of the possible different
vectors that do that.
You know, which one does it the fastest?
And this time, instead of
thinking of the fastest
as constant-length vectors,
what increases it the most,
we'll be thinking, constant
increase in the output.
Which one does it with
the shortest distance?
And if you think of them as
being roughly parallel lines,
it shouldn't be hard to convince yourself
that the shortest distance isn't gonna be,
you know, any of those.
It's gonna be the one that connects them
pretty much perpendicular
to the original line.
Because if you think about these as lines,
And the more you zoom in,
the more they pretty much
look like parallel lines,
the path that connects one to the other
is gonna be perpendicular to both of them.
So because of this
interpretation of the gradient
as the direction of steepest descent,
it's a natural consequence
that every time it's on a contour line,
wherever you're looking
it's actually perpendicular to that line.
Because you can think about it
as getting to the next contour
line as fast as it can.
Increasing the function as fast as it can.
And this is actually a
very useful intepretation
of the gradient in different contexts.
So it's a good one to keep
in the back of your mind.
Gradient is always
perpendicular to contour lines.
Great.
See you next video.